nous avons dans la salle une citoyenne
marie saint jean qui veut poser une
question le chef madame saint-jean
bonsoir à vous pensez merci merci d'être
là votre question il vous écoute en
voici lorsqu'on est âgé et à la retraite
il en coûte beaucoup plus cher de vivre
ce cas deux vous savez tout ça et on
peut pas bénéficier entre autres du
partage des revenus qu'on est seul pour
absorber toutes les dépenses alors
prévoyez vous augmentez les pensions des
retraités ou encore majoré la déduction
en raison de l'âge en d'autres mots
quelles mesures fiscales
prévoyez vous pour aider les personnes
âgées vivant seules
très bonne question très clair merci
beaucoup madame saint jean monsieur
blanchet vous répondent en premier
bonjour m saint jean le premier ce que
vous mettez en place et les remarquables
d'abord parce que il ya une forte qu à
qu'on appelle les baby boomers qui vont
arriver à la retraite une retraite qu'il
mérite heureuse qu'il mérite
passablement prospère parce qu'ils ont
construit la société dans laquelle on
vit où on propose l'augmentation de 110
dollars par mois de la pension
vieillesse en partant plusieurs crédits
d'impôt sur les activités physiques un
congé de une prolongation du versement
pour le conjoint lors du décès du
conjoint la protection des fonds de
pension comme créancier prioritaire lors
d'une faillite ou de la cessation des
activités d'une entreprise un ensemble
de mesures que je vous invite à
consulter dans le détail on répondra à
vos questions
parce que on pense que c'est important
aussi et je remercie monsieur blanchet
monsieur c'est clair que là coût de la
vie est un autre enjeu très important
dans ce grand vin c'est le thème central
de notre la forme on va rendre la vie
plus abordable pour tous les canadiens
que indienne pour les québécois et
québécoises spécifiquement pour les les
personnages et les gens là qui à prendre
qui a pris leur retraite on va augmenter
le crédit en raison d'âge par mille
dollars
aussi à beaucoup de nos crédits d'impôt
va appliquer à aller
ah les personnes âgées comme le crédit
d'impôt pour le transport en commun et
aussi on va éliminer la tps pour les
factures d'eau monsieur et pour les
personnes avec une crème fixer les
revenus fixes et ça c'est important
merci monsieur cher monsieur trudeau
merci m saint jean pour votre question
la première une des premières choses que
nous avons fait c'est d'augmenter le
supplément de revenu garanti pour nos
aînés les plus vulnérables souvent des
femmes seules
mais on sait qu'il ya encore plus à
faire c'est pour ça qu'on a promis de
bonifier la sécurité de la vieillesse
à partir de l'âge de 75 ans de 10%
ici à une personne âgée qui perd son
conjoint
c'est un moment extrêmement difficile et
c'est pour ça qu'on va augmenter
allez les pensions de survivants des
régime des rentes de jusqu'à 75% de ce
qu'ils recevaient avant parce qu'on sait
que d'appuyer nos aînés c'est essentiel
dans une société riche généreuse comme
l'anneau merci monsieur trudeau madame
mais votre réponse merci madame un sens
jacques je veux ajouter parce que j'ai
oublié un commencement que je
reconnaître que nous sommes ici peuples
autochtones ont cédé à aucun jeu dim et
gouache
maintenant je veux dire que oui le parti
vert sont vraiment engagés pour
augmenter le niveau de pension pour
aider les âges et moi même j'ai 65 ans
alors je suis absolument dont le même
position mais je ne sais pas en parler
de retraite immédiatement alors je veux
faire aussi mais se fier en stratégie
pour les années est aussi celui d'un
cabinet cédera ministre avec le but de
protéger
merci madame et monsieur bernier
mais on vient de s'apercevoir que tous
les autres chefs ici pour m
vous promettre que vous ce que vous
voulez entendre et donc faire en sorte
qu'on va augmenter les pensions pour les
aînés moi je vous dis la vérité c'est la
vérité c'est que le pays est endetté
on n'a pas les moyens et la seule
promesse que je vous fais c'est
d'équilibrer le budget en deux ans et
après ça seulement après ça on va
regarder pour baisser les taxes et les
impôts mais les gens ici il n'y a pas de
limite
y a pas de déficit et c'est comme si
rien n'était et pour les programmes
sociaux pour les programmes canadiens
c'est important d'équilibrer notre
budget tout de suite parce que si jamais
une récession dans quelques années on
n'aura plus de marge de manoeuvre
donc je ne sais pas d'acheter votre vote
avec votre argent je vous dis merci
vérité merci monsieur même je saigne
terminée oui mais si madame colocation à
et vous avez soulevé un enjeu qui touche
beaucoup de monde
merci pour prendre le temps pour
expliquer ça je pense que c'est
tellement seulement à ridicule que les
personnes âgées font face les grands
défis comme ça les gens qui on sacrifie
si beaucoup ils ont le droit d'avoir
leur retraite avec la dignité ce qu'on
va faire c'est de mettre en oeuvre des
programmes pour vous aider oui il faut
augmenter les pensions
aussi il veut il faut augmenter les
services comme la science médicament
universel qui va sauver centaines de la
doller le soin dentaire nationale qui va
aussi réduire les coûts et sauver
d'argent ou si on veut mettre en oeuvre
une limite sur les fesses c'est lui là
savent aussi son argent merci à vous
merci monsieur c est ce que vous êtes un
peu plus éclairées quant à votre vote je
vous demande pas pour qui bien sûr mais
tous les programmes sont intéressants
alors on verra dans quatre à merci merci
beaucoup pour votre stationnaire
merci